I wanted that
we're gonna play a song They're gonna
have to do interpretive dance behind us
all right my man what's your name I'm
Travis why do you rate yourself as a
dancer three what's your name Clara one
through ten rate yourself as a dancer
I'm gonna say snake [__] yeah
now I see you have your dancing shoes on
already
what is your name man Stephen who are
you here with it I'm here with my wife
and my second wife your wife and your
second wife yeah
yeah can you get that mic closer to your
you guys are a threesome
yep
and who's the dude in the white shirt
that looks like a mummy who the [__] is
that guy is
he's the driver that's our second
husband the second husband we may not
need to do a dance-off uh
ah we might just get the four of them up
here
so hey yeah [__] yeah
give me some hand sanitizer I know where
that I know where that hand's been
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you guys you do a move called the
pom-poms [__] yay
put the mic closer you used to have it
that close to your mouth uh
[Applause]
[Music]
he just thought he was gonna fight
through other people tonight he didn't
think he was getting us right
[__] hell yeah now I got so
distracted by four ticks four tits two
balls and two dicks four balls probably
four balls yeah you missed a couple
there well I don't know dude I just was
throwing it in I was making a guess yeah
well I know but tell me your name again
I'm sorry Steve Steven yeah yeah thank
you thank you ah come on SO Stephen
rate yourself as a dancer one through
ten
bye now listen
just by judging by your bedroom
acrobatics I don't believe that
[Applause]
you got some kind of rhythm going on you
know what I mean
thank you yeah it is not happy your
second wife's like he's got nothing uh
one word
to describe your dance style shitty
that'll do that'll do
if one word to describe you as a dancer
country country
all right exotic
[Applause]
if you had said that pre foursome people
would have looked at you and been like
nope
but post scores some people are like
[__] you up I want to see that yeah
give me the name of your best dance move
sexy wife number one what would you say
is the name of his best dance move or
wife number two or dude I don't give a
[__]
one of y'all
[Applause]
he's good with his hands
all right so the name of your best dance
move is the mechanic
give me the name of your best dance move
the floss the floss all right I learned
to dance to embarrass my son oh yeah
good move everybody now I want to say a
couple of rules right up front rule
number one
no touching me I had to make that rule
after the very first time we did this I
was like I'm going to make the no touch
of me real this is important
rule number two you should not touch
each other unless you ask the other
person okay
which I'm sure you have no problem
here we go you ready man here we go
you uh
[Music]
[Applause]
desire believe
when I say shake that ass I wanted that
away
that's childish everybody and they're
here one time
[Music]
[Applause]
when I say
I Want It That Way
[Applause]
I think
four plus two makes six
[Applause]
yeah I did not see that coming if you
know what I'm saying I kind of expected
something like that but I didn't expect
Chuck Norris to jump out of this
[__]
you're a third to bring the lock belt
yeah he is yeah I am saying yeah he is
he's bendy isn't he [__] yeah
oh you're one my fault okay yeah
yeah my bad dude [__]
a crazy combination of a black belt and
a porn star it's like
so and a [__] Blockbuster employee
it's such a weird combo
[Applause]
oh I can see you putting away the videos
at night 10 years ago you'd throw them
in the air and be like and kick him on
the Shelf
you are
in my fire the one here we go
desire
when I say
[Applause]
[Music]
now
get the [__] out of here I
I will save Bert we learned a little
something about you tonight
yes sir
[Applause]
look at the size of his hands oh I've
been looking at him the whole time no he
does have gigantic show everybody the
size of your hands look at that right
there
let's hear for Travis yeah
Hey listen everybody was kung fu fight
Stephen everybody and then I'm here
[Applause]
Bert
one time for Claire everybody
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
so here's what we're gonna do because I
really did enjoy tonight you guys were
all fantastic do you know who your
server is
Michael
gets a hundred dollars but each one of
your each one of your servers gets 50.
how about that all right
let's hear it one time for these three
everybody one time
[Music]